former and congressional candidate
giovanni guerrero has lived the horror
of colombia's conflict first hand
a local victim's leader he's running for
office for a special electoral district
for peace created to give a voice to
underrepresented people like him
but the return of violent confrontation
between armed groups in arauca has made
campaigning impossible
we are just sitting still trying to work
in the village talking to friends
knocking on doors when possible
more than 60 people have been killed
since the beginning of the year in a
conflict between eln rebels and
dissident groups of former farc rebels
we had planned to follow giovanni
handing out flyers and visiting a
prospective voter but as we were leaving
he had a change of heart
i don't think we should it would be a
nice thing for me to take you around
town and be on the news telling people
what my plan is what i want to do if i
win
but right now it would put us at risk
the little campaigning that is happening
is limited to the main urban center
that's because all candidates are saying
it's just too dangerous to travel to
rural areas even on main roads like this
one because the armed groups are known
to set up checkpoints at any time
the situation is also affecting regular
candidates older cassettes who is
running for a traditional seat in the
house of representatives has campaigned
in arauca for years
we are putting our lives in the
crossfire to campaign and we accept
silencing ourselves and confinement to
try to sustain democracy
he says the situation is as bad as at
the height of the conflict he's running
most of his campaign on social media
organizing a meeting in fortul is
impossible going to the town of la
esmeralda where i was a teacher and
getting 40 50 people together also
impossible
the local human rights official says
political and social leaders have become
the main targets of the armed groups
on paper everything is great the
government is fulfilling its obligation
to the victims who can vote in these
elections but the reality on the ground
is the opposite and people can't
exercise their rights
running a political campaign in a
conflict-ridden region like arauca was
never easy but this time was supposed to
be different instead threats and attacks
are once again silencing these already
marginalized voices alessandra ampietti
al jazeera rauka